it's 6 15 and it's that time again to
give someone a good day 8 news now has
partnered with albertsons to help make
somebody's day brighter let's take a
look
i met helen and ken at the albertsons on
rainbow in charleston do you spend a lot
at the grocery store
sometimes yeah some weeks you need more
than you do other sweets
sometimes it's 250 just for the two of
us they've been married for 28 years and
remember the good old days at the
supermarket i will say this i used i had
four kids
and you used to
pack the whole back
full and you hardly even spent a hundred
dollars and even though the dollars
don't stretch quite as far anymore helen
says they count their blessings every
day
it's costing more and more
but i will say this we're thankful we
live in america we have grocery stores
that we can come and get our groceries
so what if what if i told you we were
gonna make your day and albertsons and
eight news now is gonna gift you
a good day and help you with your
groceries
can we do that for you oh yes would that
be all right
yes
well we hope that this helps out because
we know the grocery bills can get big
and
we just we want you to have a good day
god bless you all
wow they were just so excited and so
sweet i had a great time surprising
helen and ken the most adorable couple
thanks again to albertsons for making
this all happen and you never know you
could be next and i tell you john the
albertson staff and all the shoppers
there they're just as friendly and so
nice and dedicated eight news now uh
viewers i didn't even realize that but
everybody was saying hi and just excited
that we were there too good stuff love
that